Did you guys hear that?
Imagine it: You’re home alone. Something goes bump in the night.
What was it? The cat? A burglar? Or… maybe a ghost?
Our minds are big and they require furnishing.
For humans, any answer is preferable to the terror
of not knowing, so we automatically create causes
to go with our effects — conventional or otherwise.
Unfortunately, the real world is complicated, and cause and effect are murky.
Even in carefully controlled studies, what works in one place
might not work somewhere else.
And if an experiment can’t be replicated, should it be trusted in the first place?
As historian Daniel Boorstin said, “The greatest obstacle to [progress]
is not ignorance, but the illusion of knowledge.”
Harvard professor Vikram Mansharamani recommends diversifying
our sources and developing our own judgement,
rather than relying just on experts. Our decisions are always
based on partial knowledge, and that can be scary.
But in a world  defined by contingency and uncertainty,
we just have to take a chance.
When it comes to public policy, what are you most afraid of?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and SUBSCRIBE for more research and videos from AEI.